stéphane marchand je le disais vous êtes
en journalistes notamment scientifique
vous êtes même ingénieur polytechnicien
est ce qu'on peut est ce qu'il est
normal que quand on quand on innove
quand on fait ce que disait patrick
jeantet c'est à dire quand on augmente
le trafic bas il ya des bugs ou est ce
que tout ça ça devrait quand même se se
prévoir un peu à l'avant alors d'abord
je remarque guillaume pepy qui est
constamment à la télévision qui est un
grand amateur de caméras c'est ici
aujourd'hui il est d'ailleurs non plus
aller chez le ministre au combat donc
très bien c'est très courageux
deuxièmement lorsqu'il ya des
innovations et des changements
techniques
évidemment il ya des erreurs de commises
évidemment il ya des bugs tout à fait là
tout à fait raison c'est vrai et pas de
problème la seule chose que je conteste
dans ce qu'il a dit c'est quand il dit
il faut toujours plus de tgv et bien non
il faut à un moment donné arrêter
d'avoir une politique qui consiste à
avoir toujours plus de tgv
il faut arrêter ça il ya plein de moyens
alternatifs de transport
la théorie de la mobilité mode qu'on
peut très bien se débrouiller sans train
il ya des car il ya déjà tout ce qu'il
ya le le covoiturage donc il faut
arrêter de multiplier les les trains
parce que le tout tgv est un problème
systémique en france regardez la gare du
nord par exemple à la gare du nord vous
avez 80% de l'espace consacré aux trains
au tgv et 20% au rer alors qu'il ya 80%
du trafic qui est dans le rer et 20% du
trafic qui est dans tous les blocs et
vous commencez à revoir les priorités et
patrick jeantet qui est terrible et ya
un an à son poste un an
guillaume pepy y est depuis dix ans dix
ans voilà donc